haití se despertó este miércoles con la
noticia del asesinato de su presidente
joven el mois de 53 años fue baleado por
hombres armados en un asalto a su
residencia de pétion ville en la
madrugada el primer ministro interino un
close del informó que el presidente
murió a causa de sus heridas mientras la
primera dama máximo ya se encuentra
hospitalizada fue mi lema de información
no creer
café con los primeros elementos de
información que tenemos nos permiten
decir que los autores del atentado
agravan al inglés inglés español para
que expand español
ataque
como jefe de gobierno aún en funciones
de apoyo en el artículo 59 de la
originación para declarar el estado de
sitio y lado del país en las primeras
horas de este miércoles las calles de la
capital puerto príncipe estaban
prácticamente vacías aunque algunas
personas saquearon negocios en ciertas
zonas
rousseff llamó a la población a la calma
loco necesitan johann moritz 71 a phil
weiss
el presidente lleven el móvil sea un
hombre valiente los haitianos deben
mantener la calma porque la situación
está controlada
el mandatario gobernó por decreto
durante más de dos años y la oposición
exigía su dimisión el asesinato ocurre
dos meses antes de las elecciones
presidenciales y legislativas previstas
del 26 de septiembre la nación de más de
11 millones de habitantes se había
vuelto cada vez más inestable y el
descontento de la población así como la
violencia de las bandas no se puede
crecer bajo el mandato de moix